thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a childish
wild ride with Stevo we've got Josh Peck
a prolific child star he got into
stand-up comedy at the age of 10 because
his mom made him and he also got into
some pretty heavy substance abuse and we
don't shy away from the juicy War
stories about that plus speaking of
substances the cops interrupted the
episode because they thought something
sketchy was going on with the hoses
running in and out of the RV like we
were cooking something we weren't
supposed to pretty pretty wild and we
were definitely talking about a lot of
sketchy stuff so strap on your seat
belts and let's get into it
okay so we're ready to go we're
recording everywhere yeah
ladies and gentlemen Josh Peck yeah yeah
dude man we connected
God it's been
four years since we first connected and
we exchanged numbers
and like texted semi-regularly always
planning to meet up and do something and
it took a long time yes it seems like it
always sets in this town was that when
you he came to the house yeah that was
four years ago yeah four years ago but
I'd seen you around kind of on campus
yeah okay the sobriety crew and I uh but
I never wanted to approach because it
just felt because I literally was like
because it's so I think we have like
about a we're about a month apart in
sobriety I think it's more like a week
on March 10th 08. yeah February 15th
and I I was like all right so we have
similar time so it's not like I'm I'm
putting my hand out to a newcomer that's
uh necessarily so I was just like what's
my motives here is it just because I'm a
big fan because if so I'll let him be
and I did well man it's a good way to
look at it what's your motives
that answers everything that is a really
good way to look at everything
um that uh time four years ago we
recorded your podcast which was Audio
Only yeah and now you've got a new
podcast which has the video the audio
the everything like and we're double
uploading double up so let's not tread
on the same subject matter that we did
on your podcast what are we getting into
Conspiracy Theory show that everybody
can enjoy both what'd you guys talk
about anything
controversial controversial or or a
clickbaity no I'm kidding
about right
walk me back to where uh it's 2008 and
you're getting sober yeah at that point
you're how old 21 21 years old and
um I I understand you were a full-on
child star is that fair to say sure okay
at what age did you become famous I
guess I I would say I started working I
started working in New York as a
stand-up comedian when I was 10. wow and
I got my first job which was a show
called The Amanda Show which was like
sketch comedy for kids Amanda Bynes like
crazy brilliant oh wow Beyond her years
Talent still is and I was 13 and that
moved me out to California and in that
day and age basically the runway was if
you were remotely funny and you're on
one kid's show you were probably gonna
get a show with your name in it too yeah
and
Keenan and Cal had been off for a couple
years they needed another buddy comedy
and here comes Drake and Josh it blows
my mind that a 10 year old is going on
stage and to be funny right what kind of
what kind of jokes does a 10 year old
have observational baby yeah
you know what's the deal with the fruit
Roma
do you remember any of your actual jokes
when you were 10. no I I remember making
I made fun of my mom I made fun of kids
at school I I didn't impress I did bad
probably like Billy Madison Impressions
and but I had a type five and I would go
to these comedy clubs
that's so great to a 10 year old is
really one minute but it felt like five
minutes probably just the audience being
nice to me and not wanting to cut my
head off what was your audience school
or like older people so I found this
agent named Sid gold gold star
entertainment the father of Elon Gold
the great comedian and uh I was reading
this newspaper I was nine years old and
I would just do like kids theater and
whatnot at school school plays and
whatnot but like any kid who plays the
Little League Dreams of being in the
major leagues I would like look around
at these kids in my school play and I'd
be like you guys got to get your [__]
game up like you really like because I
was so I loved it and they just did it
for fun and they were probably much
healthier about it but I wanted to do it
at a high level so I I'm reading this
magazine for actors called backstage
this guy Sid gold I represent performers
of all ages and I said well I qualify
and I go to his office he's like well I
I represent Comedians and if you can get
five minutes together I will put you up
at Caroline's comedy club wow yeah and
that's how it started wow were you
nervous like getting on stage at that
young of an age I think it's like
skateboarding or anything like where the
under like I I tried skiing for the
first time at 30 and I quickly was like
this is insane like this is so dangerous
this is no way to learn something and so
like anything like that I I feel like
it's better to learn young because your
understanding of risk and pain is so
much lower
okay I just like it was stand up I just
was like I I yeah I certainly was
nervous and I would know if one one
performance went better than the other
but I was a little Fearless I would say
yeah that's great man how often did you
perform your type five twice a week
twice a week for how long
five years wow and same material
no I would update a little bit because
then I would also cash it out because
I'd go perform on Rosie O'Donnell or wow
type five
Josh and Drake Drake and Josh at 12. no
and not until I was about 15. I didn't
command to show at 13. right okay and
and when are you performing stand-up
comedy on the Rosie O'Donnell show this
is a great story so I'm like 10 years
old and my mom's like typical Jewish
mother and we just go to see the Rosie
O'Donnell show but at that time she
would have people from the audience
introduce her so there's this guy
running around in a headset right my mom
being like I'm not standing in line
yeah she goes come here and she's like
got a young comedian here you need it
yeah and he's like well give me a joke I
told him a joke five minutes later we're
in the Green Room of the Rosie O'Donnell
show wow and then my mom's like well we
didn't get this far to get this far like
you're gonna tell her after you
introduce her that you're a kid comedian
and you want to sing a song and do a bit
with her and I was like yes Mom just
love me and where's Dad
and
that's exactly what happened wow so how
is it received on on Rosie and and how
much of uh of a bit did you get to do I
did a joke I sang with her we did like
some Broadway show tune something that
was in my key in my register and uh you
know at that time it was just so
I was just always ready to go like
whether it was
catcherizing Stars stand up New York
called and they've got five minutes
tonight if you want to come in and Sub
in so my mom would be like take a nap
because you're not going up until
midnight they're gonna have to sneak you
in through the back it was like
I was always ready to go at that time it
was my thing what year was that
um 90 it was probably like 95 through
wow two I mean all the way I moved to LA
in 2000. we're
um that presumably to do this bit on the
Rosie O'Donnell show like there was a
rehearsal no no rehearsal no rehearsal
so just on the Fly and in order to sing
a song you're not doing an acapella
right like uh he she had an her kind of
Andy Richter was this this uh great
pianist who was like a classically
trained Broadway piano so he could play
anything so it was like if you gave him
anything within like the last 40 Years
of the the Rogers and Hammerstein
songbook he was ready to go
um and I just remember it I remember I
think I remember the intro was like hi
I'm Josh Peck and this is a Rosie
O'Donnell show on today's show uh Mike
Myers wow Robert Wagner and Jon Secada
hit it John
oh you'll find it
and there you go
that's really cool
after you did that was your phone
ringing did you get more gigs from that
or I I didn't but I I would audition at
Nickelodeon Every Day for something like
a commercial or uh two lines on it on
one of their shows they had their
offices I'm sure where you've been a
million times at 1515 Broadway uh I was
thinking Santa Monica yeah yeah New York
yeah New York because it was MTV and TRL
shot there and and so I would just get
really close but they they really never
wanted me I would audition for this show
all that which was like SNL for kids the
best show
hold the phone folks there's a brand new
sponsor of the Wild Ride podcast and I'm
claiming it is all that it's called
Miracle made they make bed sheets which
are inspired by NASA I'm telling you
it's incredible they're infused with
silver which regulates the temperature
so you're always sleeping comfortably at
the perfect temperature and the way that
they're infused with silver prevents the
growth of over 90 percent of bacteria so
these sheets stay fresher longer no
gnarly odors and they're silky and
satiny more comfortable than anything
I'm telling you I love them and if you
go to try
miracle.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo man
you're gonna get over 40 off your order
and at checkout you're gonna get a three
towel set totally for free plus an extra
20 off your order I'm telling you this
deal is all that the sheets are
incredible so sleep like a king by going
to try miracle.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo now
let's get back to it
it's my dream oh that looks so good I
wanted it so bad and they were like
you're not ready kid yeah they just
didn't want me and but I find I booked
this movie with Chevy Chase and Chris
Elliott and Iggy Pop and Pam green and
it was a Nickelodeon movie called snow
day and I'm on set and the president of
Nickelodeon's hanging out and my mom
being who she is was like tell him you
want to be on all that tell them you
love this [__] give them a joke and I
did and nine months later he called and
said I'm moving you and your mom to
California you're on The Amanda Show
congratulations wow so sick did that
change you're like The Amanda Show
[__] man I wanted to be on all that
I really did not until I got there and I
was like yo because at 13 amongst my
friends I was certainly like maybe the
most talented kid and then you go into
like a ring with Amanda Bynes and you're
like I I have nothing on you like you're
so much further ahead of me
um now when you were going to 1515
Broadway like just on a regular basis
just showing up and just trying to who's
motivation was it was it like you
telling your mom mom I want to go and
and just show up at the building or was
your mom saying Josh we're going to go
show up at the building both
in hindsight both but you know I loved
it and I was I I was pretty good and so
it was your mom
here's the thing she's in on my mom's
crazy talented beautiful singing voice
like like my mom is marvelous Mrs Mizell
if she stayed married right like it
didn't become like uh you know a
stand-up and so when she saw it in her
kid she's like well I'm gonna give you
everything I wish I had so basically
like I started it like I started a small
fire and she just shot you know kerosene
all over it yeah that's great but I was
watching The Bert Kreischer podcast and
it was you guys were talking about how
much you made during your four seasons
of doing that
what I'm curious about is when you
become a childhood star is there any do
they teach you about taxes or like is
there a learning curve with like most
kids when they become a childhood star
and they start making this money like
what what do you do with all that money
I don't know we're not on there's no
support group but there should be there
should be a child star Anonymous that'd
be a good show I guess it's like
Celebrity Rehab
um
uh no there's no one really teaching you
and I think you just have to like hope
that you meet the right people and hope
you have like a semi trustworthy parent
which in this business is 50 50. kid
actors but luckily my mom to a certain
extent understood like you gotta pay
taxes yeah like let's hold back half of
every paycheck to make sure at the end
of the year we're taken care of were you
getting homeschooled or were you also
going to like regular middle school high
school wall filming I went to a
continuation school called options for
youth I love when people are like
where'd you go to high school I'm like
options for you you're like what's your
mascot
they're like what went wrong right
um and it was great but it was for kids
who did not fit into the standard school
system so it was Teen Moms
gang members and child stars wow that's
cool that's great at a public school
yeah it is my brother wants a
continuation
where's your brother today is he okay
he's doing great yeah he's actually got
15 years server too no way yeah is that
okay to say that yeah
you know yeah uh now uh you can move out
to California you're in continuation
school in California yeah
and
is uh the gang element the drug addict
element like introduced from school like
I'm assuming that there's like a drug
element it was North Hollywood right
North Hollywood it's exactly right at
the time it was a rough area I mean I
think that's the one thing that
sometimes misunderstood is like I lived
I moved from a 500 square foot apartment
with a bedroom with no windows in New
York with like a single mom who
understandably like it's just it's a
[__] being a parent regardless but
doing it on your own and and we just
didn't have a lot of money and then we
moved here and we had a little more but
it wasn't crazy yeah and uh and so we
moved into a two-bedroom apartment uh in
North Hollywood in like in elevated
Oakwood and it was
I mean it was 1800 a month and I I
literally thought we were in a palace we
were like we had a pool we had a
racquetball court I'm like I didn't know
I was Elon Musk like this is stunning
and I stayed there from 14 to 29 because
it was so I got my mom a nice place when
I was 18 but I stayed because I'd never
lived in a 1 000 square foot apartment
for 1800 bucks a month whoa
um so yeah so anyway that the area
though it was super transient and weird
because no one lives in these places 16
years I lived there six months so I just
remember like drugs and all like that CD
underbelly stuff it wasn't really at
school
and I wasn't exposed to it on set like
the Hollywood stuff as much it just like
was slowly around and my best friends
who weren't actors like the people I
would just hang out with after school
just it's so it's so trite that it's
it's gross because it's just somebody
started smoking weed and then weed was
the thing and then somebody tried
something harder and then that became
the thing even though we all told
ourselves we'd only be potheads for the
rest of our lives what was this
something harder well I mean I had
friends who were you know smoking speed
in warehouses I I didn't go that far but
I mean it's
their North Hollywood kids who didn't
you know there wasn't a lot of
foundational support there right were
you hanging out with other kids in North
like celebrities in the Joseph
gordon-levitt's from like Van Nuys North
Hollywood area or did you guys ever link
up or in continuation were there any
other actors
not no I mean I always had actor friends
I remember I started going to to acting
class
um when I was 15. thank God because I
had like a manager who was like you're
not good and I was like babe I'm pretty
good like are you seeing all the Razzle
Dazzle I'm putting on these jokes like I
have a show with my name on it and she's
like yeah but you're not good like
you're a [__] shtick machine like
you're a forward energy Dad please love
me like broken shtick monster and that's
not gonna work anywhere but where you
are right now
and that's proven to be correct no um so
I uh and so she's like you got to go to
acting class and so I went and thank God
I fell in love with it because I'm kind
of at my heart just an acting geek
anyway and in that class was Evan Rachel
Wood
Dakota Fanning Penn Badgley Evan Peters
like all these killers but you know they
weren't who they are today they were
just like me like young actors who
wanted to be better and it was there
where I was like oh maybe I can do this
forever because I I really fell in love
with it on a deeper level then and and
you were pretty pudgy I was a heavy boy
I was a thick I was a thick boy you guys
yeah what if I just denied it I was like
no I don't know
um
so
you fall in love with the acting I
wondered when you just start going to
this acting class
I was like 14 years old and it became my
like you know I was choice I would I
would go once a week and then I would
help like teach and by that I mean I was
I would there was a younger kids class
that they would have the 15 16 year olds
come and like assists with the eight and
nine-year-old kids who were taking class
and
and it was just it was my Foundation it
was my my uh social life I've told this
story before so I'm I don't think I'm
speaking out of school but I the first
my first like real kiss was during a
game of spin the bottle with Evan Rachel
Wood like wow yeah and it was ridiculous
and God bless her for for being willing
to kiss a young boy who wanted to know
what that felt like
um but yeah I was 16. that's great shout
out Evan thank you so much I love it so
were any not a man without throwing
anybody under the bus was there weed
being smoked in the acting class no
those kids were all good kids it was my
it was my street rat North Hollywood
contingent it was my I'm still my best
friend to this day shout out Latin what
about Nickelodeon were you guys like
sneaking off getting high then going
back and filming somewhere I wasn't like
in general like I mean like Nickelodeon
kids stars of that day like I'm sure
Shia LaBeouf Amanda Bynes
[Applause]
Amanda's so great man she's just like I
she's such a great person and then also
just selfishly I think she's literally
one of the greatest performers like I I
just I want to watch her do more stuff
but she's she's awesome but yeah dude I
mean there were so many I I think I was
like weirdly the exception but because I
was a thick thick boy I it weirdly like
saved me in the ways that I never felt
even though I had a show with my name in
it I didn't feel a part of that crowd
like that was a different level than me
like these cool kid actors who would go
to events and clubs and look Chic and
maybe were partying like I felt
comfortable amongst my group of of
buddies who were going to Grant High
School and were just like doing normal
knucklehead [__] that kids do not like
the famous Hollywood kids yeah there's a
lot of like child stars that have
stories about being bullied because
they're stars and I can never figure
that out but was that yeah
now
I don't think there are a lot of child
stars in my audience I think you guys
are adults and there's a good
possibility that you're getting bullied
into paying way too much for shaving
products
products with gimmicks that you don't
need like vibrating handles it's just
silly and let me tell you about Harry's
Harry's makes super quality five blade
razors weighted ergonomic handles
nothing that you don't need it's classy
it's what I use and
you can get this starter kit it's the
craft handle set with this killer new
craft handle five blade razor foaming
shave gel the travel cover to protect it
all everything that you need it's a
value of 17 and they're gonna give it to
you for only ten dollars if you go to
harrys.com
Stevo I'm telling you man these are the
razors that I use I've been using them
for years I love this company so go to
harrys.com
Diva to get your craft handle set right
now for just 10 bucks all right now
let's get back to it
I I went to Performing Arts High School
in New York and when I moved to LA my we
didn't know where to go my mom's like
I've heard of this place Beverly Hills I
think that's nice so we move into a uh
uh like a little apartment in Beverly
Hills for nine months and I go to Middle
School there while I'm doing The Amanda
Show and I'm used to performing arts
high school where they're literally like
whatever you need the bigger the
opportunity the better we'll make it
easy I walk into this normal school
where they're like you're not coming for
three weeks like yeah you have algebra
and I'm like I got song and dance
I can't make it and they were like then
you fail like we're not helping you to
skip school for months on end and those
kids sucked those kids were really
shitty of me and I was like oh this
isn't for me I'll go to school with the
Teen Moms okay my people yeah my sister
was going to school with the uh the
oldest son on um
Tool Time where um Zachary Ty Bryant
yeah so they're they're we all know each
other
now I remember she was going to high
school with him and it was a trip seeing
him like you know when he was in ninth
grade it's like I'll do that but like
when he goes to a party people are just
like [__] this guy not because they know
them but because they're jealous you
know it's like this guy's on TV and just
people want to hate at that age so oh
yeah I can't even imagine I mean were
you were you feeling that like when you
go to high school parties
uh yeah it was it was odd I mean as as
long ago as like in the last 10 years my
wife's younger sister was going to to
com uh to a college in in San Luis
Obispo and they wanted I was like 27 at
the time and they're they're having some
party and it's a bunch of like college
seniors and I'm there with my wife like
feeling like a chaperone and some kid
like really wanted to fight me and I was
like I I I'd want to fight me too but
why because I'm [__] Josh Peckham
what was I doing
yeah sister then
then Drake and Josh show and at that
point you're like pretty into the just
being loaded no no it wasn't until the
last I was 15. great question
uh last the last season is where sort of
the wheels fell off where I was I was I
was sewing my Wild Oats as they say how
many seasons were there just four okay
and and a season per year yeah about a
season per year and it wasn't very
popular
um when it was on it's only like become
very popular over the last like 10 years
just because of social media and and it
it just uh
people who are you know Young when they
watched it at the time that it was on TV
they got older and then their little
sisters and brothers watched it and then
theirs did you know what I mean so it's
weird yeah I mean there's no like
syndication like money or any of that
but I mean it's just yeah they just air
it a bunch right do you not get so you
don't get paid for syndication no
there's no residuals in kids TV are you
getting no residuals and jackasses I
mean not for the TV show yeah I never
saw a penny for for and they still play
anybody in Tremaine pocketing that no
yeah
wait guys it's like Joan is doing okay I
just want to make sure it spikes are the
producers of the show getting I'm sure
it's just not the actors I don't know
yeah it just was we were we worked for
the same company I think it was just
kind of a different different kind of
deal back then yeah basic cable
um so the last season of Drake and Josh
then that you're 17 18. yes
17 18. and at that time what year is it
it's uh 2005.
okay yeah so John Drake and Josh ends
and then and and you're kind of getting
speed wobbles because you're totally
loaded but uh after Drake and Josh are
you working
I was I went and did this Judd Apatow
movie like right after and again that
was on some stand up when I was 10 years
old [__] I remember auditioning for that
movie it was called job taylor playing a
bully
and on the ride there I go I think I'm
gonna do a dice impression for my entire
audition and Andrew Dice Clay impression
like no one that's a strong Choice it's
a heavy Clan no one goes like maybe you
do one line in a dinosaur
you don't do the whole thing like and I
did the whole thing in a dice impression
and literally like it was one of those
moments where I think I was so Fearless
that they were
they were like this was either genius or
terrible but we'll go with genius and I
get this part and I'm doing this thing
and it was great except I was like 19
and being a knucklehead cliche and I
just didn't I didn't show up for the
opportunity and that was sort of like
the beginning of of the the
the quick you know Express train the
sobriety yeah yeah that was that was not
a proud one
so you did get the part though yeah I
got the part I did it but I just was I
didn't show up yeah yeah I'm in the
movie you can see it yeah you're just
saying you didn't show up you were there
100 no it was a great opportunity and
it's not like Judd Apatow likes funny
Jewish guys
it's not like I was perfectly set up to
make the kind of relationship that could
have paid dividends for the rest of my
life no I just I wasn't I just wasn't
there and I didn't know I was I had just
finished this thing that had defined me
for the last 18 years and like most kids
at that age I wanted to have my college
experience and
not have to worry about supporting my
mom or not have to worry about you know
doing something that was going to hurt
me in the public eye and to an extent I
had that but unfortunately I had this
like grown-up job where I needed to show
up for people and I didn't so luckily
Judd who was incredibly cool then is
still incredibly cool and we've chatted
about it since and thankfully I've been
able to make an amends and it's all good
you know the movie didn't suffer just
because good old JP didn't bring his
A-game
but it was a good it taught me a lot
nice dude so so you're totally loaded
yeah after this movie and uh like is
there is there an intervention where
people step in and say dude like you
know we're losing you it was so many
instances it was like so many mini
bottoms of just like morally and
emotionally just feeling like
to your point that we talked about
earlier like I was um because I was a
heavier kid I had seen there was a lot
of data like had I just started messing
around with stuff at 18 like I probably
would have had to put together a
stronger portfolio against myself you
know like a a stronger defense of saying
like hey bud it's clearly not working
out but I literally had 10 years of data
saying Josh you overdo it no matter what
it is you overdo it like you aren't like
your fellows and
and it started with you know me being
heavier when I was younger and then I
got in shape and I thought I'd hit this
Finish Line but of course I had the same
mind and so I just needed something
something different so when I found you
know
uh sort of uh all the the tricks and
trades of the things that people like us
like to indulge in it was like it was a
wrap I was like oh this is so much
better and such fewer calories wow I I
don't know that uh heard of the things
we do in recovery as indulgent
but yeah it's it's way better did I hear
you right that you said you got in shape
before you got sober yeah oh wow I lost
yeah I lost a considerable amount before
wow I was under the impression that it
was a more recent thing that you had
your transformation no no like uh almost
20 years ago 300 pounds as a kid I was a
big boy yeah yeah my wife keeps saying
like you have to talk about it that much
I'm like the people they love it yeah
she's like you know you're never gonna
Escape it if you keep talking about it
I'm like it's good podcast yeah yeah
thumbnail
I just put my old face right here yeah
hey Vinnie dude dude does this give you
hope for the future I mean yet for sure
but I'm also like I also go in excess
with everything I do even in sobriety
but it's like we we pulled up to the
skate park and I remember where the last
conversation we had before
I saw Park you were like dude I only eat
like 1500 calories a day like I don't
get it let me pull up and you're eating
the pizza and I'm like is that part of
your 1500 calories yeah yeah I mean dude
so the conversation I don't know I
forgot who the guest was um
a couple weeks ago but you guys said
that you never see an old overweight
person yeah that hit me so hard yeah
because like they're like oh you see old
people smoking with their oxygen
machines but you don't really see an
overweight old person well let me tell
you folks being an old person on a
ventilator doesn't sound like a whole
lot of fun either and I think we all
know there are habits that we can let go
of to avoid having that happen and the
way to drop bad habit is to replace it
with a new good one and that's what this
company fume is all about fume is a
device which uses essential oils to
flavor air and I'm telling you man I
don't even really have any particular
bad habit I'm trying to quit I just
really enjoy my game
I have it in my pocket all the time and
I just I like it plus it's super helpful
man this company's been helping people
let go of bad habits for a long time and
they can help you go to trifem.com Stevo
and use the promo code Stevo at checkout
to get 10 off the journey pack I think
you guys know who you are who need to do
this so do it and let's get back to it
that's true I know I know and I started
thinking I was like wait you're right I
don't you don't really see overweight
old people so that like really hit me
hard and I was like okay I really need
to do something but it's just so [__]
hard dude I'm just like I'm at home and
I just like I'm like okay I'm hungry and
I'll think of some I want to eat
something and I'm looking at it like oh
I shouldn't eat that but then I eat it
anyway and then afterwards I feel shame
why is it in the house
you know like
it's awesome yeah because food is the
best yeah and it's like
I don't know dude it's just tough it's
tough yeah it's the toughest thing all
three of us are in the cult yeah we're
all in the the Indulgence
the indulgent Brotherhood
what is your audience think about the
cult
you know
um I I don't like make a point of like
hey let's get together and talk about
sobriety but it just comes up yeah you
know quite a bit and when it does come
up I feel like
uh people really resonate with it or
maybe just because like that the people
who it does resonate with they'll speak
up but I kind of get uncomfortable
talking about recovery
um because it gets turned into like Tick
Tock clips
and and you know
when speaking about recovery is the
primary purpose of an interview like I
don't want to be a part of it you know
like I agree I I I get weirded out by
recovery media because I just feel like
it Tangles up the wires so I don't shy
away from it when it does come up
um but I don't try to leave with it I
think that's probably the perfect way I
when I I wrote a book that came out last
year and and I too was faced with that
like dichotomy you sent me a copy of the
book yeah yeah yeah what's it called uh
happy people are annoying that's right I
remember I have it I love that name
that's great thanks I I and I didn't
know how to
you know sort of touch on this subject
that's such a big chapter of my life and
very much has its hands in my entire
life but especially like the last 15
years and then I just realized like I
can just sort of
talk about my experience in a general
way and then and hope that if it can
resonate in all great and if not then I
just kind of told my my side of things
but I always want to give the disclaimer
of like I'm not a representative right
you know
um and it occurs me to the on the Moby
podcast we went way into it he's got a
lot of time right yeah he's a month
apart yes
he's six months he came in six months
after me so you've got seven months on
end but we're all same here right there
he's um do you find and here I go going
deep into sobriety you find a lot of
guys you or people you got sober with
not sober anymore
I mean the the success rate is pretty
bad right I mean uh
I I
got the same crew you know really yeah
like uh you know Tommy
like Scott like like I just think that
the people who really stick together you
don't get it you know I think if I
wasn't working with you this whole time
like I would have had a lot more
struggling because it's like I I
would have been held accountable or like
you just showed up for a job but if I
was like working some [__] job just
like [__] what's the point you know who
knows like if I didn't stick to it I
probably would have a beer easy
yeah but yeah it's interesting it's
great to have uh like a real crew around
you what was the uh the last day of
using like for you
nothing special and maybe that was the
problem right it's just like it it
turned into a lot like Groundhog Day
yeah days looking incredibly similar
and just being like massively
disappointing to a massive amount of
people regularly uh and first and
foremost as I've talked about throughout
this pod like just sort of breaking my
mom's heart on a regular basis and I
I had where you know and then there's
also the part of it too where it's like
the only through line of my life that I
can tell you for sure it's like when I
was nine years old I fell in love with
acting and that's why I joined that
school play and that's why I do it
uh as cool as a Christopher Nolan movie
or I do it on Drake and Josh or I do or
this is just another version of
performance right like it's all like
I'll do it anywhere all the time or or
why I was at
hey I'm so sorry I just shot a text but
this guy just needs to look in to make
sure there's nothing sketchy happening
in here all right we gotta we got a cop
looking in to make sure nothing sketchy
happening in here sir do you want to be
interviewed let me sketch
yeah it must look sketchy with like the
air conditioning pumping in it's like we
have a Breaking Bad meth lab
[Music]
that's hilarious
but look at it we do have like a machine
outside with a hose pumping hand who
[__] knows yeah that's so funny I
wasn't even sure you knew Isaac
I still stress out even though I know
I'm not doing anything wrong yeah I
would I got pulled over the other day by
a motorcycle cop with my son in the car
and I was like and this was such a like
a sober dad moment I'm like my son is
about to see compliance like he's never
seen I'm like good morning sir
yeah I got pulled over with my son I was
like hey son hide this meth life when
um we were in uh
when we were in uh New Orleans there's
this this like homeless kid outside and
he goes dude let me tell you a joke yeah
and he says man like it's not cool to
smoke meth around babies but if you put
a plastic bag over their head then they
won't breathe it in
yeah you put that under your story
that is the funniest I'm like dude I
think I gave like 20 bucks
yeah that was one of the best jokes of
all time
um okay so uh
what um
what was going on before you linked up
with David dobrik
like sorry
did you have like like let me ask it a
different way was there like consistent
work the whole time or like did the
like the conventional kind of corporate
Viacom and Judd Apatow structure of
entertainment like fade out and then
like you had a digital Resurrection with
YouTube
I so I I've been really lucky to be
working
you know consistently but the thing
about it was like
I just had to know I knew that what I
had was just like a normal journeyman
actor's career right so maybe once a
year I would work for two months on
something and sometimes it was dope and
sometimes it was like in Hindi no one
saw and then what keeps you going is you
go on
20 auditions a year and
you know you get callbacks on 25 of them
and then maybe one of them you test on I
mean when maybe when you get maybe when
you test but like again in Matt Damon
just there was this great clip that he
talked about like for an actor just the
Callback
says so much to you because it's like
I'm close you know like I'm in the
ballpark I'm doing something right and
then if you test like all these there's
all these subtle indicators you have to
take because for a lot of us the job
doesn't come you know and but the the
mass public doesn't see that right they
just see like these year gaps where
they're like where are where are you
what are you doing what are you up to
so I I got big on social media like in
2013 inadvertently with the Vine app
were you on Vine I messed around with it
a little bit but you would have you
would have crushed
yeah I didn't
um was it like five seconds and you
could like piece it together yeah like
uh six seconds like pretty cool little
editing software built into that app
yeah it was it was great and I just did
it for fun because I liked watching
comedians on there and within a year I
was like the number one person on it
even more than Brittany furlon
I think for for a while and then she
lapped me in King Batch and all the
people who became massive on it but it
built this thing for me and I remember
in 2014
I had tested I I like it was between me
and this other actor for the I've talked
about this story so I'll just say it I
remember I like got like uh it was
between me and Rami Malek for the show
Mr Robot oh wow and I remember like and
I just remember and I was starting to do
Vine then and like it was getting
popular but I'm like [__] I was like
when I booked this show
I'm never fine again like you ain't
you're not gonna [__] catch me on
Vine and uh and of course I don't get in
of course mommy got it because he was
perfect and so good in it and uh and I
feel comfortable saying that because I
lost in in that bet and I just remember
like a day later
I get a a brand hits me up in some
emails like we'll give you a couple
Grand to do this thing on Vine if you
want and it was like legit it wasn't
online gambling and I was like okay and
I did it and I like made it was the
first time I'd made money outside of the
Showbiz structure and and how incredible
it felt to a be able to make content for
people without asking permission and B
not having to like audition five times
in front of 30 casting directors and
producers and like singing for my soup
that I've been doing since I was 10. it
was a revelatory and I was like if I do
a couple of these a month suddenly like
I'm not rich but I don't have to sweat
it like and I can take care of my mom
and like maybe marry my girl like so
I leaned in and it became great and then
I booked a TV show with John Stamos
playing his son on Fox a year later and
I leaned out and I was like I knew it I
don't have to be on the internet anymore
and I did that for a year and it only
went one season and I leaned back in
because it was a lot of this ego
fighting itself right like how do I want
to be perceived what do I want to want
people to think of me and but I knew
that again I just liked creating I
didn't really if you really asked me I
didn't care whether it was on my phone
or in front of you know on some fancy TV
show on Fox
so that leaves me that show doesn't get
picked up it's like 2016.
and it was the end of the the year and I
just was like disillusioned I'm like
I've been doing this almost 20 years and
it's just so annoying to have such
little power and our friend Jason Nash
calls me he's like I'm working with this
kid David dobrik he's pretty funny he
has an idea for a bit do you want to
come over and shoot it we did it was fun
it was easy we did it in an hour what
year was that it was like December
2016. and I just remember thinking if he
calls me to do something again I'll do
it and he called me every day for two
years like I didn't know it turned into
shooting like literally every other day
for a couple years but yeah it just was
this again like many days it was people
like Jason and me and you came around
like smart funny people were like here's
a bit let's troubleshoot it let's pitch
jokes and you felt like you were
accomplishing something and then you
were also growing and then brand deals
followed and suddenly it was like kind
of a interesting ecosystem so it was
like a fun weird side job for two years
God it's crazy how big that got man
really bad how did you feel the I mean
because it was the first time when you
did the roof bit well no the first time
I met David doe brick was
I want to say 2015.
it was 2015 for sure and it was uh like
a brand deal company
um reached out they they had uh like go
watch this movie and post about the
movie 22 Jump Street not 22 Jump Street
it was and there were a bunch of
different movies oh yeah that was good
those are actually fun they're okay
maybe maybe you shouldn't say this but
it it seems to uh be an indicator like
like almost a trend that when a movie
wasn't tracking well and it was getting
ready to really flop they would bring in
the influencers to try to like you know
throw a little money at the influencers
and have them like you know like it it
it wasn't a good sign for the movies
prospects that they were paying us to go
see it and post about it and um I had a
Mandalorian influencers yeah I came out
what movie it was and of course in this
context I wouldn't want to say it but I
went to a movie and David dobrik was one
of the influencers but at that time he
wasn't like
really big like not you know and I
remember this company too that that
booked me for that they were like dude
this kid David dobrik like is blowing up
and this is after that wow but I had
just a little bit of interaction with
them and and uh you know I can't
remember we exchanged numbers but like
we had a favorable impression of each
other yeah and and then yeah then I
don't know when the the thing was
basically he reached out says dude I'm
filling up uh my swimming pool with dry
ice like uh you wanna like jump
I forget if it was his idea or my idea
said I'm filling up a pool with dry ice
you want to come here and I was like
dude right on man like I'll jump off the
damn roof you know I don't think here
necessarily his idea to like jump off
through but but yeah I was able to like
say less
you front flipped it off off it right I
can't remember you did you did all right
Dad okay but I waited until it
dissipated enough that I could see the
pool which just makes me feel like a
[__] well you said you you talked about
I remember on the day you were like I do
the three two one and you gotta go yeah
if you give yourself a countdown yeah
I've never backed out and that still has
never failed the three two one there's
been times with skateboarding that
um kind of like because you don't make
the trick I've always committed yeah you
know I've always committed but
skateboarding's been a tough it's just
it's tough to apply that to
skateboarding but for the most part like
it's rock solid and interestingly with
three two one stunts and amends there's
been tough a mandatory I got to go
acknowledge some
crappy thing I did and it's it's not
same thing you know like you could like
it's uncomfortable you're nervous you
dread doing it you're nervous it could
hurt you yeah like uh and after you feel
[__] fantastic yeah and after you got
this footage there you're so stuck this
bridge is Gonna Roll forever or like
after an event yeah you feel so great
like it's really crazy the uh
correlation but those are the things
that I do the one two three go
it amazing how reviewing two and amends
can be about it can be so unclear where
you stand or where the other person is
with you and your life and your
relationship and if you do it and you do
it correctly it almost it's lovely and
nice and I would say the majority of the
time when people are like I love you
dude it's okay
but if it doesn't happen which is
certainly possible it reveals it's not
I've never walked away from those
situations going like wow I'm real like
I'm real scum I I've always walked
around away from those situations where
like oh man there's
they've got something to work on
themselves like not like not putting
anything on them but I'm like I did
everything I could so if they're still
angry like it's their trip there's
nothing more for me to do right and that
it can be it's it's interesting how we
all process things differently
yeah
um so with David dobrik and he just
blows up and it's crazy how active are
you on your own YouTube
I think I just I became again it was
like this two-year span where I Vine had
gone away Instagram had gone away but I
was so uh
um
sort of into this idea of whatever the
next thing was sort of conquering
whatever that thing is and so it became
YouTube and longer form and I remember
you and I when I had you on the podcast
like you had just started getting into
it you were like putting the team
together you screened one of your new
videos yeah at your house and I'm like
and again all of a sudden it's not the
people who are smart enough to get into
it in 2015 right it's like now I have
these people who I respect and look up
to like it's the lines were blurring so
quickly and then all of a sudden Kevin
Hart has a show where everyone's in a
nice spot you know what I mean like
these people were coming in Mass so I
wasn't afraid to lean in and try and
find it and
I always talk about how I spent a year
making videos that sucked and the views
were dismal and that was because I was
surrounded by so many
vloggers who were so good at it they
were Masters at it and Their audience
was huge and I was just trying to
imitate what they were doing but I never
felt comfortable being the guy in the
airport with the gigantic camera going
like what's up PEC Nation
[Laughter]
what's up wolf pack
we're getting on the Southwest flight to
Tucson like I just felt corny and people
could feel that and that was just for me
and I remember a buddy of mine was like
listen you've always made your your
career your life being in front of the
camera let me hold the camera and worry
about lighting and focus you just try to
be funny and think of something
so mukbangs were really popular during
that time which for anyone doesn't know
it's like an eating show it's all quiet
and you just listen to the song skinny
people become fat for the views
I go completely in Reverse no that's an
ASMR so mukbang the idea with it of it
was like
basically you would eat something
delicious and people would like get
their dinner and they would watch the
video while eating with you right so but
you were also trying things like trying
everything in the Buffalo Wild Wings
menu or like trying the new milkshakes
from it usually was something you didn't
see a lot of like tofu mukbangs and uh
for sure and so I'm like I could do this
and I remember I did my first one
and uh you know and I'm eating buffalo
wings and I'm talking [__] and that
video got five million views wow and
suddenly I was like oh I found my Lane
what's the demographics of a mukbang
people love it yeah we're not not gang
bangs
but like like when you were looking at
your YouTube demographics what's the
[__] uh more female than male but it
was pretty down the middle it took it it
was in it was created in Korea and it
was really like there's there are real
virtuous Beginnings to it which was this
idea of like incredibly hard-working
cultures where people a lot of times
come home at eight o'clock at night and
they're not having a big family to eat
with and they would love this idea that
someone was eating with them but then
you couldn't think of it like that yeah
like you could incorporate really
delicious food so then you're doing
something that everybody wants to eat
something delicious but few people are
allowing themselves right or like maybe
not a few people but most people are
mid-week on some kind of diet trying to
be good and you're like well I can enjoy
it through them so it was like an
idiot's Guide to Life all of a sudden
and then it branched out to me and my
buddy you know Jonah trying like the
hottest hot chicken or silly
food-based stuff but yeah that was kind
of it right the Rocks cheat day once I
like ate all the food that The Rock eats
which wow it's like 18 chocolate chip
cookies and [__] he's a wild kid
everything but the tequila but I yeah I
did everything that he ate and it was it
crippled me did The Rock between
acknowledge you doing his cheat day if
he hasn't yet he will is
I think it did okay like uh just under a
million but like it's the rock the
coolest Dwayne to ever exist
[Music]
yeah I don't know any other Dwayne's
though yeah I mean whatever I know a
couple little things so
what's going on with David dobrik now
um I saw him a while back
though big pizza he said he has a dough
bricks I saw him a while back and he
said that he's not really doing YouTube
anymore but that he's like super stoked
on Snapchat yeah is he doing long form
Snapchat I'm not sure are you on
Snapchat I have a I have a Snapchat
programming where I just worry about
making videos for YouTube and then I've
got like this this this guy who
optimizes my YouTube content for both
Snapchat programming and Facebook
programming amazing yeah and what do you
feel
because you're I feel like a kinship
with you obviously in so many ways but
to go to truly have both which few
people can say like number one movies
massive TV shows and then massive online
and uh presence is is there a preference
is there one that's better for your
overall Stevo Hood like wow what do you
think man I mean it's it's a good
question I I
um
never learn how to edit footage properly
until 2013 and you know up until that
point I was at the mercy of the
corporate powers that be how did that
feel like uh it felt fine you know like
I I had multiple
shows like TV shows some with my name in
the title like I had uh you know the
number one movies like
what like
I was out of control I get sober and
like I wasn't even necessarily ready to
get back into entertainment but
entertainment beckoned me back so there
was never like a you know like uh I'm
falling off kind of a thing but then
after Jackass 3D in 2010
I'm sober like I'm getting into stand up
uh I just felt like the entertainment
industry was done with me you know like
especially come 2013 when Knoxville was
making the Bad Grandpa movie which we
didn't really know what it was it's like
wait hold on a second Knoxville's making
a jackass movie without us you know like
it felt like we were getting Timber
licked
and was there any like we were the
jackets before
are you Chris or Patrick
um I mean there really wasn't uh you're
in and I mean whatever this is all just
perception and being sensitive and and
whatever yeah I'm starting to interrupt
but this is a massive fan of all of it
right I mean as I've told you I I bought
your too hot for TV DVD
yeah like I I know and I really enjoyed
Bad Grandpa but never for a second did I
think it was a jackass thing or that he
had left you guys and they're like oh
this is a side thing but clearly it
wasn't and we just didn't know and and
Knox has always been like he's he's just
not
um
like a braggart you know like I'm all
but like I'm like if I I'll like text my
press links to everybody I know oh
you're that guy
I'm glad we're not that close
that's not Knoxville you know so
Knoxville's got something in the pipes
like he's not making a big deal out of
it sure and so we just didn't know you
know we didn't know we found out about
it in the press and it's like and uh and
and and and I mean whatever I just made
a bigger thing out of it than it needed
to be and at the time I was trying to
pitch like some kind of TV show and it
was just nobody wanted it and I just
felt like everywhere everything I was
trying to make hap happen you know I
ended up with this one TV show and and
uh the replacement as the host ugh like
um
I mean that was that was more because I
said I wouldn't do anything with the
animals anymore and they were like well
all we really have is you know animal
gags yeah but uh but yeah I just felt
like I was like I was discarded by
jackass I was discarded by the one show
I had I was rejected by everything I was
trying to do and it was around that time
my buddy Sam macaroni was like dude you
gotta get on YouTube man I'm killing it
on here he taught me how to edit and
you know
it felt like a depressing demotion
because like dude I'm I've had my own TV
shows I'm a number one movie guy like I
want to upload
and uh I didn't even realize that it was
you know what it could be but but but
getting into the digital space just
brought about a resurrection there was a
resurre it resurrected me and
um everything that you said to to take
control to have the power to not need
permission to create my own content so
best thing that ever happened to me and
and then whenever like the the
traditional entertainment structure does
call for me like with jackass forever it
just puts a rocket ship on the other
stuff I'm doing right you know so both
are great I mean the ultimate is to have
both of them working in tandem you know
yeah
um but but the thing about the digital
space is that
yes you you control your own
creative you create your own thing you
don't need permission but God it's so
Democratic it's so transparent it's so
exposed the analytics are just sitting
right there to show if you're on the
decline you know and uh you know I was
even saying this morning because I
posted a video on on YouTube that's just
ranked 10 out of 10 you know like just
dying on there and it's a banger video
it's crushing it on Facebook you know
like it's viral on face I feel like
everything I'm putting on my main
Channel on YouTube is just and and and I
told the guys this morning I was like
you know what man like it feels kind of
Soul crushing that uh to put up a video
you think is so awesome and then it's
just dying on there
but like what color what comes to mind
is emotional sobriety yes emotional
sobriety like if I can if I can take
this as a as a sign that I gotta like be
less
uh
attached
um my self-worth my self-esteem to
external validation you know yeah so I I
just can't I came over here I was
talking again I'm like you know what
text my girl
I just texted my girl I said uh yeah I
called it a long time ago before I met
you that if I didn't learn how to have a
healthy relationship that I was in for a
dark and miserable future yeah and uh
you know and and I'm so grateful
for our love and I want to grow old with
you and
[__] everybody if they don't like what I
think is awesome
that's huge and how is she like my wife
won't even give me more than three
minutes like I'll be like I'm gonna need
to really Doom spiral right now I should
get the popcorn out you should be like
you got 90 seconds and then at the end
of that she'll be like but you know
it'll be all right right it's always
been all right I'll be like no no
this time's different yeah it's never
gonna be okay ever again she's like you
know our kids are sleeping in the other
room healthy and Okay and like like we
can like we can Pump Air Conditioning
all night if we want like we've got like
we're doing well
we lost power yeah sign went off
did the road stop
oh I wonder what but it stopped at a
perfect time right when you said that
yeah not bad
cameras are still wrong
because they're running up batteries dip
[__]
I'm just kidding it's there why that
even happened there
I mean a long period of time
the [__] air conditioning [__] us
Doug
how long was that running for on the
road yeah you're over an hour so
running the air conditioning for an hour
I wonder if it does that every time
Moby's went like an hour in a while yeah
and that's back on turn that back up
we'll wrap it up
no
is that is that are we back on
file systems are detected on your SD
card you should back up the files and
reform all this
all right so with the whole thing's
corrupted
bitty dude I mean dude
[__] bigger air conditioner uh audio
rolling
all right we can Pump Air Conditioning
all night except maybe not in the van
because it all just shut down
that was crazy it was the the the the
sign yeah it came at a good time though
man
um dude I I uh
I respect you man I I like you same here
dude I appreciate you I am
I relate to you you know like I I think
you're awesome man and and this was
great and I also think that we did a
good job of making two totally separate
podcasts that people can enjoy I agree
check it out good guys so happy to be
here with you yeah links and things and
descriptions and it's an honor boys yeah
it was awesome when we found out you
were coming on I was super stoked I've
been a fan for a long time more than
Moby yeah he said no he said
Moby was sick Moby's a hard body vegan
huh he doesn't mess around hard body
dude it's movie vegan
[Laughter]
thank you
dude I'm sitting here in England that we
got here today and I'm pretty hammered
by jet lag right now dude
um but man what a what a likable guy
Josh Peck is I really enjoy him
um it's a double upload so head on over
to his podcast to see the recording with
with me to listen to it
um yeah dude uh and and if you're in
England man the UK check out The Bucket
List throughout here plus some tape in
my special The Bucket List special in
London at the Hackney Empire July 13th
and 14th super stoked about it man no
I'm going to bed